what is up reject nation we are going to
watch
superman and freaking lois today
failsafe is the name of this episode
guys if you end up enjoying our reaction
you can subscribe and hit that
like button also follow us on patreon we
have the full length watch so long as we
sync up with the time code we also cover
a whole
bunch of shows with the same tier you
get the option for both reaction
highlights and watch alongs
included lastly major thanks to pratham
for editing these highlights for us
thank you guys for watching
we bring charisma
[Music]
where is leslie larr how could i
i can't see beyond these lead-lined
walls and you feel nothing for what
you've done
but my concern isn't for the souls of
this planet
it's for those that need to be
resurrected my own
even your soul cow there's still hope
for cal
i knew he had it in him you don't want
to tell me where laura is
fine i'll find her and bring her here
after that you and i will never see each
other again
gonna be pushing morgan to the edge
it's thinking the same thing you're
recommending
kyle take a leave from the station just
until all this edge stuff blows over
a couple weeks tops couple weeks
i'm not quite sure why people have been
singling you out but i am gonna
change the narrative make sure that they
put the blame where it should be
just give me some time
[Music]
okay i have faith
it's gonna work where's everybody going
school assembly about edge
school assembly about your mom in
particular uh where are you going
anywhere but here follow her
today's gonna be weird isn't it honestly
rather be pretty much anywhere but here
right now
we can be we could just find something
better to do
don't trust her you don't want no part
of this [ __ ]
those people are calling here non-stop
freaking out they're desperate for
answers
and i'd feel a lot better giving it to
them if we had some kind of verification
from the dod
all right time to divulge all the
secrets
[Music]
where she's headed for the dod
prepare the suit you're sinking
team up you got a buddy you got a little
buddy sam any sign of block
sir we got eyes on lar eta
impact in five seconds
cool camera movement one
when they do that sound barrier stuff
oh
yeah boy nice job thanks
man of steel 7734
i had those weapons built for the wrong
reasons
i was wrong to think you could be a
threat to the world i'm gonna take that
kryptonite and those weapons bury them
in concrete
and sink them to the bottom of the ocean
what about the environment
the environment's already too far gone
just know you lowest the boys
you don't have to worry anymore i'm not
going to try to kill you
how about you are you um you hanging out
with any water
no one where'd you get this change of
heart lady i know
she's got to be a kryptonian she loves
dod secrets yeah
to your grandpa's office you are a rule
breaker
me mm-hmm you've missed more days this
year than any other kid in school
i have a weak immune system
i got a weak immune system
he's just he's really happy right now
not releasing an official statement and
that's it but it's standard procedure
anything it's a courtesy this isn't
right it's necessary
eventually this town will be okay trust
me
but the last thing our family needs is
for this story to get out of smallville
and any quote from me will give it the
legitimacy for that to happen
kind of on his side right now yeah man
till lois wins
every once in a while grandpa's got a
point
leave and do not return until the day
is here goodbye
papa god damn give the guy a lollipop
would you or a hug or something i am
loyal to the people of this world who
accepted me
accepted you they
fear you they always will and they
should you're wrong
you should be a god
you fight against your real nature every
day
you don't know me i know the power
surging through you i know how every
moment
you make a choice to hold yourself back
because that's the only way we can walk
amongst humans without killing them
isn't it it's all about control
but didn't it feel good to lose it just
once
you are just like me i will find him
it's the kryptonian yell they always
give a comment
yeah i don't know what to say well is it
because we're a small paper
lois what is he hiding what
i don't know chrissy are you lying right
now
no you're supposed to be on the side of
the people
not the man i thought we were in this
together chrissy lois if you can't tell
me the truth
then maybe you should leave guys
well between your mom and your
grandfather there's no question
she heard about my grandpa what they're
saying that edge was
experimenting on his employees who is
she the daughter of
i don't know my cousin said that she saw
avery fan's mom fly
i heard about that that's it's crazy
right
what did your grandpa think keep your
lips shut jonathan
this is a reason you got that cover at
the beginning
teagan why did you bring me here i mean
you weren't interested in me last week
and then what i don't know jonathan they
just
wanted information well we're also
hanging out
okay multitasking everyone wants to know
what happened
and obviously you want to be the one to
tell them that's right i get it
you're the real villain of the show i
used to come here with my golita
she'd tell me stories about my family
we're originally from mexico but we've
been in smallville for generations
on kyle's side that's right it always
just made me feel like i had somewhere
to belong i never really felt like i
belonged anywhere
all i'm saying is that it only really
takes one person to change your whole
life
just to make you feel safe and you have
john
and you have your family and you have me
and that's
never going away you should probably
kiss me now oh yeah
he's got a weak immune system
it's especially weak right now that's
enough youtube
you're under arrest we need 7734. these
weapons can kill you yeah that's why we
need them
clark people like me without these
weapons
were indestructible and if something
like this should happen again without a
plan in place without a
fail safe that would be the end damn
that was sam's plan the whole
one weakness i guess we'll keep the
weapons okay i guess
that's what you really want superman i
guess i can just develop more too
if i better be mean the statement not
now lois it's important
what's wrong it's about clark worried
about him
hello oh hey kia
arrested uh were they arrested for
ditching school
yeah truancy must be yeah we do john
skipped class
why everyone skipping class today you
told my dad to keep 7734. i did i did i
should have talked to you first
it's the right thing to do this isn't
about edge is it this is about you
lois i almost killed john irons but you
didn't but what if i had
who would have been next if weapons like
that exist
then the wrong people will get their
hands on them and then what do we do
it's also a good point jordan's arrested
not enough to skip school this one has
to go get arrested
they're both acting out we'll give them
a punishment
we'll call the punisher i'm right you're
wrong i understand
lois will you please just listen there's
nothing you can say that i want to hear
and now i'm angry and i feel sorry for
yelling at you but i also have to stay
angry
so that i can scare the hell out of
jordan so why don't you just stay here
what a day looks like
lois has been pushed to the morgan edge
everyone in this episode i'm on her side
now
she's a damn good actress what's going
on
they were caught trespassing out by
atlas pond when we were there
we used to go there all the time i don't
know what to tell you other than a
private property
just because she let you two go with a
warning doesn't mean it didn't happen
mom don't talk yet cushing's
had a real problem here honestly sheriff
i was suspicious of morgan edge from day
i mean
honestly oh you
ass who knows what kind of perks they
got from lana's special little
job zero perks
lana we got lied to just like everyone
else
just like you lied when you said you
were gonna help us
and all you're doing is covering your
ass so you don't feel the blowback come
election time
lois you got another story
or a reason to tell the truth also
both clark you are wrong
plus we have to have a plan why
because your mind is corruptable we have
proof now
your heart is stronger than your mind no
you don't understand oh that's so sweet
my dad taught me control i have been
controlling my powers
every second of every day for almost 40
years
but when zod took over for the first
time
i've felt what it was like to let go
the world needs a way to stop me i don't
think that will ever
happen lois but on the off chance i'm
wrong
and if this will make you feel better
then fine
let's have a fail safe but there is no
way
in hell i'm trusting the dod with this
then we just have to find someone we can
john henry irons i know
it's you want me yes
i'm trying to move on remember now that
killing you isn't my singular purpose in
life
and it shouldn't be you came here to
protect this world from me that's what
i'm asking you to do
how close i am
i mean clark should probably call
sanford yeah clark could just fly you
both there
save some gas on your suit i wasn't
expecting to see you you were right
i lied i can't write this story
i'm too close to it to be objective but
you can
it's a statement he wouldn't go on the
record about everything but this is
enough to tell most of the story and to
focus the blame where it belongs
on morgan edge this was really messed up
lois
i know
[Music]
not alone all this time i've been
without anyone
of my kind alone how could you not tell
me
is it of no consequence to you
mm-hmm i'll find another way you will do
no such thing when i find the eradicator
i'll show him
what we can do my way is the only way
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
ha ha
what ice vision
maybe you're right kyle maybe we just
pack up and get as far away from here as
we can
no i like you on the show i know now
things are finally calming down so when
you're done being grounded
you guys can go back to being normal
teenagers and
believe me small towns are actually a
lot of fun small towns are a lot of fun
i'm just trying to give him something to
look forward to sounds vaguely
provocative
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm sold on my small town
long ago did this start a couple minutes
sir
oh seven seven three four let's get it
going
yeah you gonna be real glad you didn't
dispose of all those weapons
oh doom it's like a demon possession
movie
wow not even the kryptonite can stop him
he has become the demonic god
no god totally
like her too
it's got no pulse
[Applause]
he's gone where the hell did he go
[Music]
uh
wow that was crazy at the end
i had something to look forward to
wow i guess you can see him morgan
got pushed to the edge oh yeah and maybe
over the edge
he's very edgy today peter
eradicator just sounds like i said
educator so he's the eradicator
yeah now he's the eradicator he's the
eradicator
the last son of krypton
or something or something i think it's
their own version for sure it's their
own version that they're doing in here
yeah
it's a 100 their own version
wow what a fascinating turn of events i
didn't see that coming at all
no what was his life growing up
taro it was just just she was just in
that cave with the red thing just
being tortured every day that's your
training and your upbringing just stand
here and if you want
not good enough you can't stand back
there if you ever want to do anything
else you're weak and i hate you and
you're the disgrace of your people
damn that's a [ __ ] life to lead
that's a shitty life it's a yes you
can't blame him for being
in one breath you can't blame him for
being the way he is and also you know
you see the parts of him that
you know could have been salvaged
because he seems to know that this is
terrible treatment
yeah it's too bad man that's too bad i
really like the way that was shot at the
end
it felt like demonic possession movie
yeah yeah
like the trailer for neil blomkamp's
demonic is what i was thinking about
from watching it
oh yeah well i mean he does just i was
like what the hell's happening right now
but
yeah the flashback clears it up are you
saying like you doesn't his dad say
because oh he's telling he's telling his
dad i don't want to die
in the process he does like give up his
life he has no vitals
he's merely this vessel now this
otherworldly being
that will further be explored and
explain as we keep going
um but yeah i mean that's just the
ending of this sprinkled in throughout
with
you know angsty teen morgan edge
and uh an angsty adult morgan edge
thanks the adult morgan edge i could
watch way more often than that
repetitive flashback yeah of just
him under you're abusing me father yeah
no i'm not you're weak you're suck can i
have love now
please please give me love love now that
you wouldn't even ask me
yes um yeah but it was a great episode
really really um
one of the kind you like yeah man no
action
all talking and character moments
but yeah i mean it had a lot of like uh
really
nice i think and compelling arguments
yeah especially well the discussion
around
the uh the existence of 7734 and what
the dod should release
i was back and forth on it yeah as an
audience member i'm like whoever
seems to be winning in the argument in
this scene i'm on their side vince
yeah for now like when it came to what
the dod
should or shouldn't say or if they
should say anything at all i was like do
you know freaking general sam's right
you know he often acts like he's got a
stick up his ass but
i think the guy's right on this one and
i do like that discussion of
journalistic integrity and then how it's
affecting her
relationship and the result that it
ultimately came to at the end
what is that woman's name at the gazette
sophie is it sophie no it's not sophie
it's uh someone else's name is sophia
it's
it's something it's an it's one of those
caller gazette girl
gazette gal so gazette gal
and her um
i thought it was a little interesting
after everything they had been through
of how this one thing where clearly
she's really tied to the dod she's like
maybe you should leave
you don't have a journalistic integrity
you're out here
you don't have any scruples whatsoever i
feel like there ought to be a little bit
more of a discussion
that you would have in the relationship
they have built yeah it seems like at
least a little bit of like
what's going on like like i don't know
something to suggest that
they're i know it's risky in a position
where it's like well she runs the paper
she can print whatever you want but it
seems like they have
a confidence and a friendship built
enough that lois could at least be like
look here's
here's my position well the show does a
good job on raising the stakes of
of the of what happens when you publish
something
you know and i like movies like that
like the post or spotlight
films that deal with should we publish
this
yeah you know what will go wrong if we
publish this and they managed to keep
that with lois's storyline here in the
show
and you know i do like how that affects
her so much of having to go against her
journalistic integrity
and how this this episode in particular
where
i always love how the show is constantly
exploring the gray area but here
specifically everything was gray there
was just
something that's that's where the
flip-flop kept coming in of
damn yeah you're right even right down
to the whole thing about journalism when
clark's like we play it fast and loose
yeah when it comes to this yeah about
your secret but about this stuff that
we're
investigating on no we don't play it
fast and loose we have to
stick to you know it's it's a constant
argument that they're having
and this show managed to in the way it
was
directed because that's you know one of
the story lines here but the way it was
directed i like
how the problems you really feel just
keep compounding and compounding to the
point you start seeing it in the editing
style where scenes start moving
quicker and quicker and then it starts
getting more handheld and handheld right
when
jordan if they learn that he's arrested
it's just like it just doesn't stop and
then it's like lois is just really being
this time i'm not saying it for a joking
matter she really is being pushed to the
edge here
and i thought her performance was just
great of just trying to
handle everything i got dad i got clark
i got
sons who are skipping school this life
is a pain in the ass right now and i
can't
seem to get anything right and what does
it even mean to do something right this
is
nothing makes sense anymore it was
wonderfully executed um
for for a great dramatic tension episode
here
and that discussion about 7734
uh yeah i agree that they should have it
implemented it
you know for the episodes themselves
have had moments where you're like well
thank god that's right like there have
been
times where it's come in handy already i
mean pretty much
when edge's first part of the plan went
off you kind of see like okay
well it seems like they planned for this
for a reason
and i do like the nuance with which they
have developed that and and
it made for an oddly sort of realistic
feeling back and forth where sam's like
i i just i agreed to get rid of them and
now you want to keep them
and and i love yeah just the debate that
they make out of that because you know
you could
see there being a way for clark to have
some kind of i don't know
you know self-blaming motivation for
doing this but at the same time
like yeah i i do get where he's coming
from and that
i thought they made a really compelling
argument out of that whole mind versus
heart
thing of like lois is so confident he
will never make that turn again
and and it's that linchpin of like it
just happened to me
but you also just proved that you know
you wouldn't be lost to it and i feel
like that comes back really nicely to
you know the core debate of superman a
lot of the time and i thought it was
really
interesting that they gave him that
extra nuance of like yeah when zod was
inside of me i i
i felt that you know that that ability
not to maintain control over everything
all the time and it felt
really good and i wonder what that
feeling the residual effects of that
will
be going forward not that i guess i
expect them to be huge
but they're significant well it's like
the taste of a drug
in a way that's a good way to put it
specifically acid
uh-huh or pcp yeah
you guys know yeah comment below down
below
choose a dragon how hard it is to stop
once you do that one the fun
yeah it was all really well scripted in
the way
that was all progressing i did think
that the conversation around
the idea of other kryptonians or people
on yeah
the kryptonians the the idea of them not
because it seemed to be all about how um
we had this in place specifically to
stop you superman
and now that you know sam's come around
and being like i could fully trust
clark he's like oh we should shut this
program down i'm like
wait a minute what if clark needs backup
what about all these other kryptonians
you have two in jail right now this is
you can't just shut this down
clearly rogue kryptonians is a
possibility yeah
yeah and also we've got at least one guy
from an alternate universe who knows
who might else show up from an alternate
universe and so
i mean he does say that thing about like
we'll keep a few around you know just in
case
but yeah especially and you know
obviously it's it's planned this way
because then you see with morgan and
it's like oh
good thing they saved those because
superman probably will need a lot of
backup yeah and maybe we'll get tag
tab was his name tab maybe we'll get him
back
who the kid who had powers yeah or did
he asian kid yeah
tag yeah tag right yeah tag yeah
no no he went to jail maybe he'll come
back or he went to he went to special
school whatever that was called yeah
dude maybe he'll come back and fight
with superman
maybe and the dod or amanda waller will
come in
yeah that's right with the suicide squad
to kill morgan and
properly advertise the upcoming movie
well yeah i mean the debate's good
good debates all around good bait i feel
like there's one i'm missing
oh the storyline kyle and lana i mean
yeah
them being ostracized from the town and
and having
just every single facet of their lives
upturned by it i mean it doesn't seem to
get any better for them
no it doesn't and i mean i think they
did an interesting
job of at least i mean definitely
exploring the the downsides but i
thought it was funny that they brought
it around at the end with clark being
like
ah there's a lot of great fun stuff
about a small town you know when like
most of this episode we've been seeing
how small towns
can actually depending on what position
you're in be very
isolating and insular and uh and
yeah yeah it's a good poor kyle
and poor john too i don't know like i i
jonathan is like the best character
ever but also like the more things that
have like i've it's weird i got past a
point where i was like oh no
jordan jonathan one of them's going to
be evil i guess that's like way
old yeah but there is a there is
something that crept back for me in this
episode of like what is going to happen
with his character
because like it seems like a lot of
his scenes do you know like he does seem
to have this bum luck or this this sort
of
uh streak of mishaps or or these moments
that are
like that broke my heart for him when
you know it's like she takes this
interest and then clearly she's just
trying to
you know weasel information out of him
and i'm just like it's another
you know another thing for this kid to
contend with and it must
feel so lonely because even that moment
where it's like you know and then
tomorrow you go back to being normal
kids or whatever
and like well john goes back to being a
normal kid you know jordan gets to still
be jordan and even though john's cool
about that you know it still affects him
sarah was right about her look out
i don't know look out maybe she did want
to actually hang out with him too
i could feel they might be doing i mean
i bought i got that out of her
performance of it of like oh
she does kind of feel bad at that i bet
she'll see him next episode yeah be like
i'm sorry about what happened
let's just hang out and not talk about
your grandpa
he's like i'm gonna walk home and he
said but john
all right i won't drive and follow you
and be like just get in the car i'm
sorry
we could talk about whatever you let him
walk he was right you don't need to talk
about anything
yeah rest your head on my shoulder
kendra felt that bad if they didn't have
that scene
no you know driving yeah just come on
get in the car
she got on the phone she's like mission
failure yeah
i'm ending this live stream
don't forget to like and subscribe damn
more dod secrets yeah everybody skipped
school
today it's really easy to skip school
there it seems like yeah
except they'll except the cops will find
you and john henry irons getting the
keys to see he got everything he wanted
when he didn't want it
yeah that's perfect that's that's
literally gotten everything he set out
for
except for actually eliminating the soul
of kalel he has gotten pretty much
everything he needs
don't worry next episode maybe he can
eliminate all the rest of the souls of
krypton and that'll that'll
you know balance it all out i think john
diggle i mean
i don't know how much of a cop out of b
if john diggle does come back as green
lantern
i don't know if i really want that for
because i like how this show feels
so isolated from the rest like diggle's
the closest to
the most upfront connection to the rest
of the arrowverse
on cw i jus i so like a part of me he's
going oh my god i mean it's an
eradicator
you probably need at least john henry
irons by your side
just launching everything from seven
seven three four throw the swords
through the spears or the knives
we have missiles start with the blades
yeah start smallest and then work your
way up
bio weapons last we only have like four
or five
but how do you defeat the eradicator
that's the big question
right yeah like yeah he nothing affects
the guy
the crypt the kryptonian prison didn't
do anything he
broke rather he goes right to the sun
just absorbs all the radiation
that's a threat right there he's
unkillable that's a major threat level
i hope this season has a crazy
um just daunting
cliffhanger i just want one worm like oh
damn
the eradicator won
multiverse last shot of the season is
just his boot heel crushing superman's
head
yes yeah man
it's good stuff also yeah the scenes
with kyle and lana
um it's funny because i i didn't
like i i this is the most i've ever been
uh connected to their relationship in
times of hardship this is when they're
pulling through together as a couple
and now i'm really tethered to their
tethered relationship now i'm really
uh invested in them as a couple i kind
of like them as characters individually
but as a couple you really see that
strong unit
and plus jordan too freaking mackinaw
and sarah in the woods even the cops are
like arrested
them for public displays of affection
the daughter [ __ ] of that
uh woman [ __ ] yeah she's that morgan
edge [ __ ]
yeah bitched us all into being [ __ ]
from morgan edge
damn you blame you guys gotta take
everything out on her now
and her husband and her made me believe
in him we will not
you made me believe the thing i wanted
to believe
at all costs it is what what it is
getting to a point though i gotta say
where i'm like why is everyone blaming
why
how come there's not people why aren't
there people like
in the streets going kill morgan edge or
something like that
everyone really seems to not have no one
seems to be playing
morgan edge they're just blaming the
people who
who uh the main people who uh champion
for morgan edge
where i guess you could i can see the
scenario where someone might come at me
with saying that
well morgan edge is not a part of
smallville kyle lana grew up
with these people they are a big the
town that is like a family
so they feel that their family let them
down uh by inspiring them to go along
this path
ultimately same time
though it's like well they didn't do
this it was it was
morgan edge did this so i i feel like
there should be
some people there's got to be someone to
stand up for them
guys not just lois but there's got to be
someone to be like that's not their
fault
somebody would be able to see that they
had been manipulated too
yeah you know yeah even the mayor's
being a freaking oh god
about it didn't trust him right away
he's the most two-faced mayor he has two
scenes
and they're both opposites yeah man i'm
gonna help out
i'm gonna [ __ ] talk you sure you're a
jerk you dumb
you should be you should not be
re-elected man that's the next season
it's about getting the mayor not
re-elected
lois runs for mayor should be a good
mayor she'd be a good mayor
or maybe kyle could be the mayor you'd
be a good mayor too john mayer
john mayer new album out now mayor john
mayer video mayor mayor
yeah excuse me mayor mayor
and then oh first name mayor last name
mayor
middle name john middle name meijer we
need more
john's on this john yeah on the show
we're running low on john they stopped
john and john from bonding and i felt so
bad they got
jonathan they got johnny irons they got
john diggle we need more
john's on this show yeah man i'll join
the show
the john variants yeah the john the john
to verse it's a good episode
it was a good episode good ass episode
good debates
poor kyle i like seeing him be like
finally towards the end of the episode
though be the one to support her
because throughout most this episode
it's like lana's holding it all together
and then finally kyle's like no no lean
on my shoulder it'll be fine
well yeah i mean kyle's the one who's
been suffering what seems like the most
direct
abuse from the small build town even as
firefighting people are turning against
them yeah man
i know can't trust firefighters police
you can always trust always we've
learned this
can never trust firefighters man what do
they do for anyone
especially lance d'or if you're watching
that
well guys what did you think about
superman and lois there's another good
installment
it's not my favorite of the season
that's that always sounds like you're
talking [ __ ] when you say that yeah you
hated it now
it's not my favorite episode i don't
know why you gotta declare that what if
you're like six seasons in you're like
it's not my favorite of the series
it's like odds are it won't be yeah
[Laughter]
the more episodes you go just the better
the odds are it's not going to be just
because
not every next episode needs to be your
favorite yeah
just like not every season can be your
favorite it's still a pretty damn good
one for sure
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to john's solo channel
the john traverse the john diverse
subscribe to
anyone else who want to just find a
random channel type in
just slam your keyboard in the youtube
search engine first person to pop up
click that like button and uh
check us out on patreon thanks for
stopping for and then the highlights
we'll catch you guys soon